all right the mvp is essentially down to
three guys although at this point i
think we know who's gonna win it it's
gonna be aaron rodgers 48 touchdown
passes more passing touchdowns for green
bay this year than punts we don't have
an mvp award we have an offensive player
of the year award a defensive player of
the year award a rookie of the year
award and a coach of the award now these
are pftpm awards i don't want to confuse
anyone but you will see over the course
of the next few days the official pft
awards on the website we have all of the
ap categories and a couple more this is
just for the purposes of this show and
there are three winners for each award
because we don't want to duplicate the
selections that we've made so with that
understanding so we're all clear and on
the same page
offensive player of the year time mds as
always you get to go first
well i'm going with patrick mahomes and
although i agree that aaron rodgers is
the favorite for mvp
i think patrick mahomes is setting up
for the kind of career where we look
back in 15 or 20 years and we said boy
you know patrick mahomes won a bunch of
mvps but he should have won even more of
them i think he is going to play just at
this consistent level where
if he's not the clear-cut mvp he's right
in the conversation i do think he is the
best player you can you can argue he
didn't have the best year you can argue
that aaron rodgers had a better year for
my money patrick mohames is the best
player in the nfl has been now for three
years
i agree with you mds i might throw aaron
donald in there but he obviously plays a
different position but i am going to go
with the guy who is going to win the mvp
award i can almost guarantee that it's
not going to be unanimous because i know
there's going to be some people who vote
for josh allen and possibly patrick
mahomes but aaron rodgers you letting
you are you voting for josh allen
usually
i actually voted for aaron rodgers but i
do know some people who voted for josh
allen and i considered it strongly
because i think he has a great case but
roger's led in completion percentage
which is normally a drew brees
area of leadership that's we know drew
brees year after year leads in that he
led in touchdowns he led him fewest
interceptions he led him passer rating
every big category he let in and the
packers were just terrific so it was a
tough decision mike because i think josh
allen deserves it just as much as aaron
rodgers does
yeah and josh allen is my offensive
player of the year and i feel bad
because we're not giving derek henry
any recognition in this but he will be
most likely the ap offensive player of
the year with that 2027 yard performance
but josh allen
was
phenomenal this year
i don't know why he didn't get more
credit for what he was doing i think the
problem is
it didn't really take off for him until
after the hail murray game although he
did have some great moments early they
started strong we all paid attention
then they had the dip against the titans
and the chiefs and that's when we kind
of like well okay
good start but yeah you're not really
ready to be one of the great
quarterbacks in the nfl and then he just
kind of quietly snuck up on us week
after week the last six games of the
season and became one of the best
quarterbacks currently in the nfl period
and and i think he's been inspired by
what he sees patrick mahomes do he
realizes that he can move and he can
throw and he can do a lot of the things
mahomes does throwing across the body
throwing on the run
i've i've talked to people very
knowledgeable in league circles who
quietly will say
if they had to choose between the two
right now they would take allen for the
course of the career because he's larger
and possibly more durable than a patrick
mahomes would be remains to be seen how
durable both are over the long haul but
that's high praise for josh allen
because there is a sense by some that
patrick mahomes is in a class by himself
there are others out there who think
that josh allen is in that exact same
class so he's my offensive player of the
year defensive player of the year time
mds who do you have
well shireen mentioned you could argue
he's the best player in the nfl it's
aaron donald you know he's already in a
select group of players who have won the
associated press
defensive player of the year award twice
he's he's in that group along with mean
joe green mike singletary bruce smith
reggie white ray lewis but i think he's
about to enter the three-time winner
club which is only right now lawrence
taylor and jj watt
he's in a very elite territory i really
think we're seeing one of the all-time
great defensive players when we watch
aaron donald
agree with you mds and you know the
defensive player of the year awards
almost always turned into a pass rusher
award and i realized it didn't happen
last year as to find gilmore won the
award xavian howard had a better year
this year than stephen gilmour had last
year and deserves to be in the
conversation and i don't think he's
probably going to get any votes because
i think it's probably a two-man
race with those past rushers but i think
he deserves some consideration at least
with 10 interceptions he had a 46.1
passer rating against him he was just
terrific this year mike in every single
way for the dolphins they went out and
signed byron jones xavien howard was
better
you know back to aaron donald mbs
um
if if i was a lions fan and i know mds
you're not you're a well-documented
hater of the detroit lions uh
i would still be tormented by the fact
that the lions took eric ibran over
aaron donald at a time when both and
dominican sue and nick fairley were
entering i believe the final years of
their contracts with the team and it was
an obvious area of need what in the hell
were they thinking
to take ibran over aaron donald now look
we didn't know how great he was going to
be but there were indications he was
going to be pretty damn good and
obviously he is there were indications
that tj watt was going to be pretty damn
good although some think he was a first
round pick or at least thought at the
time he was a first round pick only
because he was j.j watts brother no that
was one of those picks when the steelers
drafted it was like damn that that's
just one of those we should have seen it
coming this guy is quintessential
steeler pass rusher extraordinaire led
the league this year with 15 sacks he's
got an energy he's got a relentlessness
i think he had a huge role in getting
that team in the right mindset in all
those games played in in an empty
stadium with yellow bright seats
everywhere you look and watt told me
himself that they've struggled with that
they have to bring their own energy and
constantly work on their other teammates
to get them where they need to be and
what is just that that bundle of
football energy and emotion and talent
and everything mike tomlin said recently
he's from another planet i think he is
as it relates to his football skill and
it'll be interesting to see
if what he did siphons any votes away
shireen from aaron donald it could be
that aaron donald's unanimous if anybody
else is going to get votes i think it's
going to be tj watt all right rookie of
the year time not two categories not
offensive and defensive one bucket
rookie of the year mds who do you have
i have justin herbert and i just love
everything about his rookie season i
love that in his very first start
they come to him a minute before kickoff
and say hey the team doctor just
injected tyrod taylor in the lung you
have to go and he looked totally poised
and ready in that game and i love all
the way down to the end of the season
how well he was playing one of the
reasons i don't like these tanking
discussions is i think we don't
celebrate the teams that are out of it
but are still playing well in december
which i think really describes the
chargers who who i thought played very
hard even after they were mathematically
eliminated i think justin herbert start
to finish of his rookie year he was in
command of that offense i think exceeded
expectations as a top 10 pick when
you're top 10 pick you got high
expectations i think he was even better
than we thought
i think there are three rookies mds who
stood out above all the other rookies
and we have the three of them right here
and you guys the two guys you picked are
going to fight it out for the offensive
rookie of the year i don't think there's
any question that chase young is a
defensive rookie a year and that's why i
picked him he's just been terrific
7.5 sacks 12 quarterback hits he has 44
tackles four forced fumbles and he's
just gotten better as the year
has gone on some injuries early on in
the season but he just gets better and
better and better and really has played
well
he still has a lot to learn learn though
mike rookie mistake calling out tom
brady after last week's game
yeah what was the other rookie mistake
that he made earlier this year oh was
that stupid unforced error with
the
roughing the passer against matthew
stafford in the lions game remember that
and he caught it a rookie mistake it's
like dude this isn't your first year
playing football you know you can't just
knock the quarterback onto his ass well
after the ball has been thrown you don't
have to be a 10-year veteran to know
that in the nfl but uh yeah uh the the
comment about tom brady that just adds a
little juice to the saturday night game
although chase young can back it up a
lot more than anthony smith of the
steelers who guaranteed a win over the
patriots back in 2007 and had tom brady
in his face all night long i don't know
that tom brady wants to be in chase
young's face all night long on saturday
my rookie of the year justin jefferson
the minnesota vikings first couple of
the games of the season they didn't use
him much what makes what he did
after that even more impressive
ultimately setting the team's
rush uh rookie receiving yardage record
and correct me if i'm wrong did he set
the league the nfl single season rookie
receiving yardage record i think he may
have here here it is most receiving
yards by a rookie 1400 since bill
grohmann in 1960 so impressive year for
justin jefferson i knew he had beaten
randy moss's record of 13
15. and and when when you're in that
kind of territory number one it shows
he's going to be great number two it
shows they did the right thing moving on
from staphon diggs that relationship was
fractured they've got a mixed history at
best of drafting first round receivers
this one hit for them and this is a guy
that i think they need to think about
moving forward building their offense
around that's how good he is coach of
the year time for 2020 mds who do you
have
well i have sean mcdermott and the
reason i have him is not just that the
bills of course had a very good season
but also
whenever i watch the bills i just feel
like
everything about it is sean mcdermott's
coaching kind of falling into place you
know some coaches come in and they say
they've got a plan and they're going to
change this and they're going to change
that and you're never really sure you
buy it i feel like these bills are
playing the exact brand of football that
sean mcburt mcdermott was preaching
in his first year i think they're
they're a smart team they're they're a
team that can make big plays but they
can also play tough physical defense i i
i feel like they're just the right team
they're the team sean mcdermott told us
they were going to be
uh you know i haven't gone back and
looked at his introductory press
conference but maybe i should because i
just feel like whenever i watch these
bills i'm watching exactly what he laid
out when he first became a head coach he
was talking about the kind of team he
wanted to build
i feel like these bills are that kind of
team
i'm going with kevin stefanski for the
same reasons i mentioned earlier first
playoff birth since 2002 first winning
record since 2007 they've had four
coaches in three years counting interim
coach greg williams and he seems like
he's the right choice mike just
unfortunate for the browns and for kevin
so fancy he's not going to be there for
the playoff game this weekend
and look i think stefanski will win the
ap coach of the year award and it is a
tough
award to gage because it's
i i in my mind it's the coach who best
exceeds the expectations that we had for
his team going in and because of that it
makes it difficult for a guy like matt
lafleur because we already had high
expectations for the green bay packers
but my goodness 26 and six in two years
on the job managing aaron rodgers who
can be if you haven't heard a little bit
of a difficult personality matt lafleur
has already created a standard where he
could be coach of the year every year
like a bill belichick he's never going
to win it
as long as aaron rodgers is there
because we're going to expect him to be
12-4 11-5 13-3 but he deserves
consideration and he's my pick for coach
of the year as we wrap up this
discussion
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports